All right.
Bing Hackman, thank you
for being on 20 Minute leaders.
How are you?
Terrific. Interesting times.
Interesting times, but you seem to be
in one of the nicest places in the world.
What is this background?
So this actually is
a background that you might be more likely
recognize. It's Yad Vashem
overlooking Israel.
Is this right
right at the entrance of Yad Vashem when -
The backside. The backside.
The entrance is closed, you go through it.
This is the backside there's a view.
So this is right after
you're in this dark room
and you see all the faces and all
the names and then you go out to the light
and you see the beauty of Israel.
Is that right?
The countryside.
Right.
Wonderful.
Well, Bing such a pleasure to have you.
Coming from an industry that
I really know nothing about.
Now, you don't really, you
deal with real estate
but you don't really deal with,
you know, a small apartment investment,
like I hope to be a part of
or that you know,
the average person deals with.
But you really deal with massive,
massive real estate considerations.
You mentioned a few
of them right before
but I'll let you take it away and tell me
a little bit about what it means
to you and how you've sort of
paved your way through this
and then we can move on to some other things
that we want to talk about.
Sure.
So I did feasibility studies for projects
for Stanford Research Institute,
SRI,
international private sector
shopping centers,
apartment buildings,
office buildings,
industrial -
The Monterey Bay
you told me, right?
Monterey Bay
Aquarium -
I love it -
... facilities, convention centers,
arenas, stadiums,
performing arts centers,
recreational facilities, Calgary,
different places.
Fort Dodge, Iowa.
A wide span.
Go into a community,
you learn all about it,
and you kind of understand it.
When you get into a more complex area,
L.A., San Francisco,
there's so much that goes on
it's a little bit harder to see.
Anyway, I went from there
MAI Appraiser.
Wait. Wait.
What is the feasibility tester?
What is that even mean?
So I look at other development.
I see what it costs to operate,
what it costs to build,
what revenues they generate.
And the feasibility
is having the revenues generated,
cover the cost to build
and create a profit.
So it's like you're gonna build
an apartment building.
You know, here's what it cost to build.
Here's the rent you're gonna get.
And so does it make sense,
does ... make sense?
So let's take for example,
the case study
of the Monterey Bay.
So you actually look at,
OK, what is this actual,
given the structure
that we want to build
and the prices,
how much is this gonna cost us?
And then you take a look at
the ticket sales and the projections
Simple story.
I looked at aquaria
all over the country
and I saw what the staffing was.
I saw what the use days were.
I saw what the traffic was.
I looked at the different types of
exhibits that had greater appeal.
I presented that to David Packard
and his daughter Julie,
who was a marine biologist
with ...
Marine Science Center next door.
And they looked and they said,
"That's all fine, but we're gonna go big"
So here's an idea of what
you're gonna get into
and then here's what they decided to do,
which is a wonderful thing.
So we gave them a foundation
base of the general expectation
and, you know, obviously they're pretty
capable and understanding, insightful.
And so then they chose to do what
they did, which was terrific.
Wow. That's incredible.
And it's a great setting, anchors a tourism area
made famous.
So, it's not just real estate.
It's really it's hard core economics work
to really understand all of the moving
pieces and whether this is
an economically viable opportunity.
That's right.
You look at what goes on elsewhere.
You understand that.
You see how it applies
and what kind of, you know,
in other types of properties,
what kind of market share in this one,
you know,
what kind of tourism is there
and how will that feed in?
So it's that kind of thing.
So I have to ask,
when you deal with projects that are,
you know, tens or hundreds
of millions of dollars,
how granular do you get in terms of the,
you know, the estimates?
So, for example, in this case,
how exact do you try to be
in estimating the potential revenue?
It's like an appraisal.
Again, after SRI,
I became an appraiser.
After becoming an appraiser,
I worked for a high net worth individual
and bought office, institutional quality,
opportunistic investments
in the Western states.
So, office
R&D, industrial properties
and in each case, just like an appraisal,
you're looking at the revenues,
the expenses and the returns.
And in acquisitions, you're looking,
you know, what are the risk issues?
I would find properties with a lease
expiration in three years.
It was too small for institutions,
too big for private.
My guy, he was perfect.
He has 40 of these, you know,
a couple of 'em roll out.
It's fine.
Anybody else?
If they only have one,
you know, they can't handle it.
So you find a strategy
that works a unique niche,
and each case is, there's a real world
operation that's similar.
And so you're comparing it
to those to find, you know,
what the value would be,
what the opportunity would be.
And in terms of granularity, you know,
appraisals, you know, they try to get
to be 90% accurate in their values.
Ninety five.
And there's a lot of variation,
a lot of subjectivity. Think about,
go look at a stock analyst
on any big company.
You're gonna see a range of opinions
that is stunningly broad.
And that's all subjective and they have
extensive information to draw from.
But, you know, you have
a variety of opinions.
And so with anything
that factors in there
but you hope to
get repeat business, so you try
to be reasonably on top of things.
Wonderful.
So, you worked for this individual
and then you move on
and then you mentioned MIA.
Right?
The Member of Appraisal Institute, MAI,
was after SRI
before acquisitions.
Lots of abbreviations
it gets complicated.
Yeah.
Now I'm working
with Colliers as a real estate broker.
I do investment sales
and I do help tenants.
I like helping tenants.
They need the help of other -
The landlords
have all the information.
Tenants are struggling to survive.
The rents are very high
and we try to, you know,
even, level the playing field a little bit.
Definitely.
Okay.
So, Bing an expert in economics.
Talk to me a little bit about
what's happening now,
because you know,
coming in at 24 and just
starting out my sort
of my economic life.
This is a pretty interesting time.
Yeah.
Give me a little bit of context about--
... backing up that
People have been saying
how awful things are and they've been
saying that for a period of years.
This is the best time to be born
in the history of the planet
and if you want to talk about
demo, work,
you want to talk about vision care.
You want to talk about opportunities to
raise a family and to get an education.
Right now, we have an unbelievably
unique time,
but we started out with a healthy market.
What people don't understand
is there's two and only two drivers
of long term GDP growth
and GDP isn't everything
but it's a central metric.
And those two drivers are
labor force growth and productivity.
So when somebody tells you
they're going to grow the economy
at 4%, they essentially have
no understanding of economics.
Short term, tax cut, spending,
whatever, you can blip it.
Long term, you have to have those two elements
and if you do, you'll have -
And again, one percent per year
with productivity,
one percent per year,
labor force, two percent
is a healthy GDP growth in the current world.
We're gonna go to 10 billion people,
we're at seven five,
then we're gonna shrink back down,
according to demographers
I'm not a demographer
that's what I hear.
But right now,
we have a good economic base.
We have a lot of pent up demand
that's going to express itself
once we get things wrapped up.
I don't know what the damage will be,
nobody really knows,
but we are incredibly fortunate.
And the thing that really strikes me,
really strikes me today,
is the opportunity
we have to see that
we're all in this together.
You know, I feel like we're in a time
of more intense tribalism
than I've ever felt.
Yeah. For sure.
And why?
You know, we should be advancing.
From an economic metrics point of view,
as I view it,
we're actually better off
compared to most of history.
We all have our thoughts on the topic.
But, you know, and I also note that
a healthy community
is different than tribalism.
But for me right now,
there is a profound lack of perspective.
So I'd like to talk about that a bit.
100%
All right.
Okay. So, let me just share something
on my screen here.
Please.
'cause this is, I think, tells a story.
Can you read that?
Yes, I can.
This is by Albert Einstein.
I think most people know who he was:
A human being is part of a whole
called by us the universe.
This is a part limited in time and space,
and he experiences himself, or she,
thoughts and feelings
as separated from the rest
And it's really kind of an optical
delusion of our consciousness,
as Einstein puts this.
This is a kind of delusion's
that really a prison for us.
So, we see ourselves
as separate and
at odds with each other,
and our task is to free ourselves
from this prison
by widening our circles of compassion,
embrace all living creatures,
the whole creation and its beauty.
This is the central theme of
pretty much every major tradition.
Right.
And this is the perspective that's lost.
We see our little silos.
We see our little tribes.
We don't see our ethical imperatives.
We don't see our connection.
Right.
And another great visionary,
Abraham Joshua Heschel,
"When I take the time to look,
there's wonder in the commonplace
and wonder is commonplace"
And I want to reflect on that
just a little bit.
For me, the big picture helps
put things in perspective,
by which I mean
if you took all visible matter in the universe -
big topic -
70% is hydrogen,
27%'s helium,
97% is stars.
The other 3% only
is all the other elements
on the periodic table.
Here we are,
on a carbon based speck of dust
in a Goldilocks orbit
around a heat source
on which there was an algae bloom
oxygenating the atmosphere
and we live in an oasis
on which life has spawned
in a incredibly hostile universe.
Right.
And we understand the magnitude of that gift
for you and I to have this conversation.
For us to raise a family
or to pursue whatever we might.
That is a perspective that I think is sorely lacking.
We're disconnected from nature.
We're disconnected from our connectedness.
Right.
And we're all part of the same.
And we're unique expressions of that,
but we're distorted expressions of that.
You know, all great traditions
helped to reduce our distortion.
What do they want it to do?
The common theme is seeing and feeling
everything and everyone as sacred.
Can you imagine if we all felt and saw
each other and this oasis in that light?
And it's again expanding
our circles of compassion.
Another thing that's important
is to have a sense of the magnitude
of our ignorance,
our silos and our echo chambers.
This is a Gallup poll
that I've looked at
for 10 years,
running and it repeats each year
the same outcome.
Gallup,
I still don't believe this
but look it up.
The percent of adults in America
that believe in creationism,
the earth is 10,000 years old
creationism,
40% in America.
So, we have,
40% of Americans
believe that the earth is 10,000 years old.
Yeah.
And, you know, obviously,
we've lost our faith in science.
It's a lot of chaos.
We're emotional beings and creatures.
And so what do we do?
You know, that's the big question.
Well, we start with really looking
at our actions
and our interactions
with others around us.
A major theme, again,
of all traditions.
I'm gonna start with Amos.
That book of the Bible is like 750 BC
So add 2000 to that,
2800 years ago.
They were saying
righteousness and justice
is what's paramount.
And then you go to,
I don't know,
let's say 350 BCE is
when Plato wrote The Republic,
which centered as a theme justice
and why is it that nice guys finish last?
Why is this?
Why is that?
But it was also the
great appreciation of reason.
But we remain emotional beings.
But justice is a central theme,
and it's really an ethical imperative
for all major traditions.
Right.
So what's happening?
Let's understand this a little bit.
I took a course in religious literacy
and people understand
violence as direct violence.
But violence is more than that.
It's structural violence
and it's cultural violence.
So what do I mean by that?
If you are suppressing opportunities,
you are creating structural violence.
If you're vilifying,
if you're demeaning,
you're creating cultural violence.
And you know most would be appalled
at direct violence.
If you had,
you know,
police showing up with police dogs
and fire hoses
and running people down
who were peacefully protesting.
Right.
That would be appalling.
But people are not appalled.
They're insensitive
to cultural violence
and structural violence,
which are just as egregious.
We need to better understand how we
contribute individually,
directly and indirectly.
Think of the Black Lives Matter.
The southerners used the Bible
to justify slavery.
And sacred texts
are for revealing and inspiring
a sense of the sacred.
To use sacred texts to justify
exploitation, historical claims, oppression,
it's an egregious violation
of the second commandment,
one of the foundations of
humanity's aspirations.
There's a very,
I'm gonna repeat that actually.
Sacred text are for revealing,
inspiring a sense of the sacred.
To use sacred texts
to justify exploration,
historical claims or oppression,
is a horrific violation
of the second commandment.
And you know, if we learn nothing
from history,
such sacrilege by religious zealots
has been the cause of many wars
and much suffering.
So what's the lens
that we want to look at?
I'm going to quote
Pierre Teilhard de Chardin
he was a Jesuit.
"The way we treat people
is the way we treat God"
Very clear.
Think of trauma.
You have an oppressed situation.
There's great trauma in that.
And that trauma compounds
if you have opportunity.
It's like having a dollar.
It grows, it invests,
and it grows over time.
If you don't,
you have a cycle of poverty
that cannot be broken.
Vilifying others is cultural violence.
Condoning and supporting it is, too,
even if only indirectly
Constraining opportunities of others
is structural violence.
Separating others,
limiting or preventing
exposure and interaction
causes cultural violence to fester.
Conversely, facilitating exposure contact
reduces cultural violence
that builds bridges.
We need bridges, not walls.
A quote that I'm gonna cite
is really a beautiful one.
It's from Kurt Tucholsky
"A country is not what it does.
It's also what it tolerates"
And, you know, we've probably heard
Micah and there's a very famous,
you know, I guess verse, book
Micah 6:8
"He has told you, O mortal, what is good
and what does the Lord require of you
but to do justice,
love kindly,
and walk humbly
with your God"
And to me,
this perspective, connection with nature,
connection with the being
that we're all part of,
and seeing each other as a part of that
is something we need to move toward.
No, no Bing I completely agree.
I would love to you ask a few questions.
Do you mind stopping the screen share
just so that I can see you again?
And I think that really
what I'm what I'm curious about,
and I think it's extraordinary
how much thought
and meaning you put into this.
What I'd love to know is
where does this all come from?
So, you know, coming from economics,
working on really incredible,
incredible deals.
What brings you to be so passionate about
this idea of our mutual responsibility
to be kind to each other
and to be part of this creation?
Where does it all stem from?
Okay.
So I graduated college 100 years ago
and I had to decide what the heck am I going to do.
And so I started thinking,
Okay, gosh, I don't know.
It was back in the 60s.
I thoroughly enjoyed the 60s,
but that's another story.
But it was a time of reflection
and you know,
did I want to go into service,
did I wanna do this.
I want to do that.
Do I want to be a business person?
And I realized that what I need to do
to understand how to navigate
my life is to see what's important.
And to me, what's important is this:
what is the nature of creation
and our role in it.
And that theme has been with me
through these decades as a central
point to ponder in all the opportunities
that I've had.
And I lived in Los Angeles
and had numerous opportunities
to look at different traditions.
I've traveled the world, India, Israel,
wherever to look at centers
and meet with teachers
that I thought were helpful in some way.
We have such a cornucopia of resources.
It's absolute extraordinary.
So it's basically, you know,
my central journey.
The other things I do
certainly are practical.
I like to refer to it as practical misses.
I think that's where my surprise stems from
because, you are
a very practical guy.
I mean, there's economics
is one of most practical things,
I think to study unless you're a theorist.
But I think that it's still extraordinary.
And I, you know, we have just just
one minute left.
But I'd love to ask you my last
and favorite question,
which is three words
that you would best use
to describe yourself.
Well, as I think about it,
I thoroughly enjoy looking into things,
exploring.
And so I guess probably what I'd say
is I'm just a fascinated explorer.
I find it fascinating.
I'm fascinated by it.
And I can't think of anything
more interesting or exciting.
So I'm a fascinated explorer.
That's wonderful.
Okay.
So I'm gonna take that as two words
but I think that they're so grand and so,
you know, they can mean
every person can
interpret them in a different way
that it just alludes to more.
So I'll take that happily.
I put a word a in front
so that's three words.
You win.
It's wonderful.
Bing, thank you for the time.
And thank you for sharing your thoughts
on our mutual responsibility.
I think it's wonderful to have
both you know,
a very practical livelihood on one hand
but then thinking about
the larger picture things
and I love that you chose
the background of the view,
right out of Yad Vashem
with all the symbolics that it has with it.
And you know, some of the viewers of this
don't know necessarily about
Yad Vashem and what this represents,
but really it represents life after,
you know, the worst possible place
you can come from.
It's ... you know
I've been to Yad Vashem
quite a few times
and really it's an extraordinary feeling
coming out from this darkness
up and seeing this
this beautiful countryside.
And I think that our talk also resonates
a lot with this idea of
we're in a very difficult time,
but we can always step back
and look at the look at the beautiful
world that we live in
and what's our responsibility to maintain it.
Bing, thank you for the inspiration
And hopefully appreciate with wonder,
fascination and curiosity.
I love it.
The incredible gift that we have.
Thank you Bing.
Thank you very much.
Bye bye.